[Music]
a cop in toronto has been
uh
suspended for three months oh no and
also a demotion what do you do steel
poutine
stupid canadians stupid dumb kids what
did you steal hockey pucks
[ __ ] sell fake maple
they actually fired at a man who had his
back turned oh
and they missed
this close
oh he was running so he's getting fired
from being a bad shot that's what it
sounds like right now he hit something
how can you miss something so closer
she hit something else yeah that's a
female officer she fired at this guy
she pulls him over yeah right
she basically has like bond villain aim
by the way like holy [ __ ] bond henchmen
name but yeah she pulls this guy over
and she thinks he's driving drunk
and then he immediately gets out of the
car and starts [ __ ] taking off
running a stolen car we don't know but
then or we don't know why he's not armed
he's not armed but he looks like he's
running towards the car no he's right
yeah he's running backwards he's running
away from her and then she fires and
misses him
and then
he just gets on the [ __ ] ground puts
his hand hands over his head and then
her partner arrests him
and so she got in trouble for shots
fired she got in trouble for missing
no no how do they know if uh
that wasn't a warning shot or did she
just admit he can't do warning shots
right i think warning shots she's like i
tried to shoot that dude in the butt and
i missed they determined that it was not
a warning shot it was a lack of judgment
i don't know what the laws are there but
i don't think you can shoot people from
running away from you no you cannot and
so that's what she got demoted so that's
the lack of judgment is to pull her i
thought you're going to say some [ __ ]
like she [ __ ] hit something else and
i'm like oh my because that bullet's got
to go somewhere it's not like golf
[ __ ] thank you
you missed something and then that's it
it's like
yeah there's consequences yeah she even
owned it too she was like yeah i totally
like freaked out freaked out
and she put this is this one
should it be cops
is this another case for why women
shouldn't be caught you know what i mean
well we know why men should have
we already know why men shouldn't be
cops so
why not include them too too i know
equal yeah yeah nobody should be cops no
not even cops yeah for real
and they say that because she basically
immediately owned it
um they promoted her again they're to
promote her to lieutenant no okay
they see her action since this event and
the observations of those supervisors in
a position to observe her behavior has
demonstrated that she has the potential
for reform so or to be rehabilitated the
only way to reform is to shoot a police
calendar
for 12 months and miss yeah
we should teach cops to miss yeah if
i've learned anything from this
especially bro i've seen some videos in
the u.s where people are running away
and they just start blasting dude all
the time
a lot of guys are really not prepared
like some some dudes they join the
police because it's just a stable job
they have good benefits yeah and
when you see like the way they take care
of their own fitness or how often they
actually shoot or practice the things
that you need to be a cop it's almost an
afterthought yeah it's like oh that's no
it's just i just go to work
versus like but then when [ __ ] happens
and you need to call upon those skills
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah i gotta
actually do work [ __ ] like hands
shaking or they just chased after
someone your heart beat it's through the
roof and you pull a gun out of course
you're gonna miss like this yeah these
are like stats that uh most cops never
pull their gun that's their whole career
yeah and then some cops just have never
have any ammo because they're all and
some cops shoot every day i haven't i
have a neighbor that was a cop and he
was like i don't even like guns dude
and i'm like sword cop i'm like i think
you're getting a sword
ridge of cops
don't be a firefighter i'm like a bobby
dude i'm like why are you in this job
that's all right dude you're allowed to
it's okay it doesn't work the best of
neighborhoods so if you do need to use
your gun you're going to be in trouble
you're like sorry i don't use guns yeah
your kid might not have give me some
numb chucks
ninja stars
he should have been a ninja it's just
badges but sharp
i only have one
oh [ __ ]
it just comes back
i will i will admit i think um obviously
it's a [ __ ] huge accident if you will
to just fire your gun
but to at least like willingly admit it
take like the demotion and like publicly
be like like that is that does show
signs of reform and you know it's canada
so at least i kind of believe it or it's
like signs of having a whack lawyer
when they're like just say sorry
out here they'd be like we're gonna
fight until the end like they'll give
you three months off or or signs of
actual justice hey don't worry about it
sandra signs of possible actual justice
lawyers like you know what you're wrong
was that cctv footage yep oh okay yeah
cause i was like that's at least better
than like you miss you're like
oh [ __ ] oh you missed and then finally
you're like yes i finally hit them and
they're like oh [ __ ]
uh
i'm gonna get the fingerprints
oh this is shopping
first it's all on cctv yeah
uh yeah i missed all the dialogue is in
it
they're like why were you doing like a
liar liar monologue yeah
she looks like a russian like accident
scam guy like a guy that walks up to the
car
oh
my arm
we have one of those uh today as well oh
so
yeah um but so she i have to mention she
also previously shot and killed a man in
the same parking lot
uh in 2000 same one 2013. yeah
yeah she was clear she did this before
she did this before she's but she's
pretty good she didn't miss
so she's kind of lost her edge a little
bit the other one the other one
the other one she was trying to miss but
she hit him no the other one she
no this this man had taken a little
warning shot so he had to take another
man hostage with a knife like this kind
of [ __ ] oh
yeah she actually okay good call she
shot the hostage she shut the hostage
yeah so she was [ __ ] extremely good
back then she's a she's a high stakes
performer when there's high when there's
high stakes she gets played
she needs to guard her yeah she needs
like some [ __ ] defense but when she's
cold she's cold you know what i mean
dude and in 2010 she was involved in a
shootout with a drug kingpin where she
was able to fire and shoot his bullet
before his bullet hit
she's super comfortable
she's super comfortable completely
[ __ ] lost it do you think it is
either you're in the military you know
that bullets can hit each other and
that's a common thing right
she also curves bullets i've seen one
where they shoot and then it goes into
the other gun and i plugged it see
you see what i'm saying and the gun
blows up she's a bollywood action hero
bro
she's in bollywood did they get the jeep
rolling in the other cctv
and the horse going under it
in slo-mo sliding through like this we
got some new footage here from the case
this new cctv cam is 240 frames per
second gets sued by t-series immediately
for showing it in court
so
this this lady for real wait for real
was in a a previous actually shot a dude
in the same parking lot
was it really a hostage situation it was
really a hostage situation a man was
experiencing a mental health crisis so
she saved a dude's life
by killing the mental health crisis dude
she killed the mental health crisis
she killed the right guy she killed
everybody so she shot the hostage and it
went through and it hit the guy in the
back that's exactly she purposely missed
the vital organs uh no they there's like
that diehard movie where like the guy
grabs bruce willis and then bruce willis
takes his gun and shoots the guy through
his own shoulder yeah he shoots himself
[ __ ] that's vengeance that's the hard
vengeance [ __ ] he
but you couldn't really hear him say it
because they're trying to get a pg-13
rating so they get pk mother and then
the gunshot happened oh it's kind of
wacky yeah you can only get say [ __ ]
once
and that's for samuel l jackson only it
was a pg-13 it was the leaf the free or
die hard
also a recent one yeah it was the fourth
one that was good best one i think i
only know the [ __ ] nakamoto tower one
that's the first one right dude die hard
with the vengeance still holds up
is that the sam jackson in new york one
it's my favorite one with jeremy irons
that's the best one where he throws the
knife on this [ __ ] which one's that
one the third one where they're trying
to put five gallons of three gallon
water bottle how do you get four gallons
in the fire
that's right that shows so good fort
knox one yeah it was all diversion dude
the whole time the best part is when sam
jackson's just driving along and then he
looks to his left out the window and
bruce willis is there's a water spout
and bruce willis comes out of it and
like sam jackson pulls over
oh
that was so dumb
that's the best one
really good you know there's an
alternate ending to that movie because
um you know with the ending where he he
just takes out the guy in the helicopter
he takes up
his brother in the helicopter there's an
alternate ending one where bruce willis
sits down with him in like a diner or
some [ __ ] and um
he plays russian roulette with him but
with a rocket launcher that's sick what
the [ __ ] that's way cooler it's so
[ __ ] sick so like they're like
turning it around and he's like oh like
i bet you don't know which side's the
right side and then bruce willis is like
yeah okay we'll see what we'll see and
all the [ __ ] and then sure enough the
bad guy shoots himself with the rocket
launcher and then bruce willis dies
immediately
the diner explodes
[Laughter]
explodes but he flies out of it sam
jackson's like
there he is
it's such a great [ __ ] stupid
happenstance i love it i still love that
movie though so the guy that was
uh
got the gun pulled on he wasn't even
committing anything like lethal or he
was just johnny
he was cleared so he he got cleared of
all charges they dropped the charges you
just had to take a quick [ __ ] so he's
gonna get her in her defense though it
is hard to shoot like a moving target
even if it's close it makes it faster
way [ __ ] harder
but then um that's why people rather
have like a person to deal with a knife
like yeah i mean uh you rather
have a bad guy with a gun than a knife
because it they'll they'll close the gap
but this closed brush can't hit this
this
available
i don't think we got him yet
and then they would have been like oh
[ __ ] that's the wrong guy
[Laughter]
plant some crack on him then he's
covered he's like completely dead and
then like all right let's find out what
this guy did yeah
that's america who's got an idea and
then they're like all right uh body
cam's on again body cams off and go
[Applause]
[Music]